wer von euch hat schon mal darüber
nachgedacht wie der Strom eigentlich zu
uns nach Hause kommt über Stromleitungen
klar aber wusstet ihr dass er vorher an
drei verschiedenen Märkten gehandelt
wurde wenn es hart auf hart kommt erst
15 Minuten vorher außerdem müssen
Netzbetreiber heutzutage teilweise
mehrmals am Tag eine Notfalloperation
durchführen nur damit unser gesamtes
Stromnetz nicht zusammenbricht und vor
allem die Art und Weise wie unser
stromarkt und unsere netzregelungen
gestaltet sind benachteiligt erneuerbare
Energien es muss sich also etwas ändern
was genau das erfahrt ihr in diesem
Video
bevor wir so richtig einsteigen wir
konzentrieren uns hier in diesem Video
erstmal auf den hauptstromarkt es gibt
noch super viele Sondereinrichtungen wie
den Regelenergiemarkt oder Dinge mit
sexy Namen wie mindest
Einspeisevergütung die betrachten wir
aus Zeitgründen heute aber alle nicht
wir wollen ja nicht schon wieder ein
einstündiges Video machen denn das Thema
Strommarkt ist echt krass komplex aber
legen wir erstmal los wie funktioniert
unser Strommarkt jetzt gerade nun es
gibt die die den Strom herstellen die
die den Strom zu uns liefern und die die
Netze betreiben damit der Strom auch bei
uns ankommt und dann gibt es noch die
Speicher
[Musik]
sie alle haben ein großes Ziel quasi den
heiligen Gral dass die Frequenz im Netz
bei plus minus 50 Hz bleibt denn damit
aus unserer Steckdose Strom kommt müssen
wir immer in etwa so viel Strom
einspeisen wie wir gerade auch
verbrauchen sowohl zu viel als auch zu
wenig kann kaskadeneffekte verursachen
die das Netz zum Kollabieren bringen und
selbst wenn dieser Totalausfall
ausbleibt zu viel oder zu wenig Energie
im Netz sorgt dafür dass wir über oder
unter 50 Herz kommen was kuriose
Nebeneffekte hat z.B dass unsere
Radiowecker und Backofen Uhren schneller
oder langsamer laufen und nicht mehr die
richtige Zeit anzeigen ihr könnt euch
wahrscheinlich vorstellen dass das bei
so vielen Akteuren gar nicht mal so
einfach ist denn viele Strom Erzeuger
können nicht so einfach mit einem
Fingerschnippen mehr Energie herstellen
sie brauchen Vorlaufzeit sprich
irgendwer muss vorher sagen wer wann wie
viel Strom brauchen wird und das machen
solche Menschen hier
und da das mit dem Zukunft vorhersagen
immer so eine Sache ist gibt es als
Unterstützung sogenannte Lastprofile das
ist eine auf 15 Minuten genauer
Aufschlüsselung wann ein ans Netz
angeschlossener Verbraucher wie viel
Strom verbrauchen wird bei großen Kunden
wird das auf der Grundlage von
kontinuierlichen Messungen und den Daten
aus den Vorjahren errechnet bei
kleineren Kunden wie zum Beispiel bei
euch zu Hause oder dem Geschäft um die
Ecke macht sich aber keiner so wirklich
die Mühe das genau zu messen für euch
gibt es Standard Last Profile die auch
auf 15 Minuten genau berechnet werden
und es gibt die
differenzbilanzkreise die Fehlplanungen
bei diesem standardlassprofilen
ausgleichen aber das wird ja schon alles
zu kompliziert ach ja und bei allem was
mit Wärme aus Strom zu tun hat gibt es
das dann auch noch mal aufschlüsselt je
nach Außentemperatur
das Ergebnis sind auf jeden Fall endlose
Excel-Listen hier mal aus Spaß die für
Remscheid naja spannend die Remscheider
gehen anscheinend überwiegend um
Mitternacht ins Bett cool mit Hilfe
dieser Lastprofile geht unsere
bilanzkreisverantwortliche dann shoppen
und bestellt Strom den bekommt sie am
europäischen Strommarkt also natürlich
nicht sie selbst sondern eher ihr
Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel ein
Energieversorger wie die Stadtwerke
wahrscheinlich macht er das schon lange
im Voraus und zwar am Terminmarkt hier
kann ein Stromversorger mit
Lieferfristen von ein paar Tagen bis hin
zu über einem Jahr von den
Energieproduzenten und anderen
Marktteilnehmern Strom kaufen das ist
interessant weil es Planungssicherheit
gibt vielleicht sind dann am Tag selbst
die spontanenmärkte günstiger vielleicht
aber auch nicht in jedem Fall kann der
Energieversorger dem Kunden so einen
stabilen Preis garantieren vorausgesetzt
natürlich Russland und Frankreich drehen
nicht am Rad
Frankreich warum denn Frankreich genau
dazu kommen wir gleich der Terminmarkt
einfach gesagt aber nur einer von drei
Märkten was die gewöhnliche
Stromversorgung angeht denn wenn man ein
Jahr im Voraus Strom kauft kann es
natürlich gut sein dass man sich
verschätzt oder man auch sonstigen
Gründen Strom für morgen shoppen möchte
für diesen Fall gibt es den day
ahead-markt dort wird Strom für den
Folgetag gehandelt hier kann man sowohl
verkaufen was man zu viel gekauft hat
oder eben zu kaufen wenn man zu wenig
hat oder man ist zum Beispiel Besitzer
eines Kohlekraftwerks und stellt fest
dass ich den vor einem Jahr verkauften
Strom gerade günstiger bei meinem
Nachbarn mit dem Windrad einkaufen kann
als ihn in meinem eigenen Kraftwerk
selber zu produzieren auch dann kann ich
hier noch mal Handeln es kann aber auch
sein dass selbst die Planung vom Vortag
nicht passt was ein Problem wäre wir
haben ja schließlich unseren heiligen
Gral dass das Stromnetz stabil bleiben
sollen daher kann am Intrade Markt auch
bis zu 15 Minuten vorlieferung noch
Strom gehandelt werden und spätestens
hier beim day hat und Intrade kommt
jetzt auf die Frage nach dem Preis und
spielen das sogenannte married
order-prinzip
zum Beispiel wenn ich zusätzliche
Strommengen brauche und es darum geht
wer die jetzt liefert die günstigsten
zuerst das sind die Erneuerbaren dann
Atomen und dann Kohle und Kraftwerke die
auch zusätzlich Wärme verkaufen wenn gar
nichts mehr geht müssen aber auch
irgendwann die reinen und teuren
Gaskraftwerke hinzugeschaltet werden die
immerhin im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen
innerhalb weniger Minuten hochfahren
können es gilt jedoch das Kraftwerk mit
den höchsten Kosten das zu finalen
nachfragedeckung benötigt wird setzt auf
den Börsenpreis für alle anderen
Stromproduzenten das ist die married
order der Effekt wird Uniform pricing
genannt und sichert allen Kraftwerken
die selbe Vergütung in unserem Beispiel
heißt das dass auch der eigentlich
günstige erneuerbare Strom plötzlich
sehr teuer ist das Ganze ist übrigens
kein Gesetz in dem Sinne sondern einfach
der freie Markt in Aktion sagen wir zum
Beispiel ich bekomme von meiner Oma
immer einen riesigen Korb Äpfel
geschenkt alles was ich dafür
investieren musste sind 30 Minuten nicht
um sie bei ihr abzuholen und vielleicht
einmal 20 Euro für einen Korb aber es
sind viel zu viele die kann ich nicht
alle auf einmal alleine essen daher
möchte ich Sie freitags auf dem Markt
verkaufen mein Standnachbar hat aber
natürlich mehr kosten bei seiner
Apfelproduktion als ich also nimmt er 10
Cent pro Apfel oder okay es war vor der
Inflation sagen wir er nimmt 30 Cent pro
Apfel für wie viel biete ich meine Äpfel
jetzt an ich bin ja nicht blöd also
natürlich auch für 30 Cent und genau so
funktioniert die merit order
okay aber zurück zum Thema jetzt kann
die Last für den Markt zwar vollständig
gedeckt sein aber für das Netz sieht das
gegebenenfalls anders aus denn manchmal
liegen das was gehandelt wurde und das
was das Stromnetz wirklich leisten kann
soweit auseinander dass es zum
sogenannten redes Patch kommt nehmen wir
an es ist ein Mittag im November der
Wind bläst fröhlich vor sich hin es gibt
im Norden Strom ohne Ende in Bayern
scheint heute aber keine Sonne und
Windkrafträder gibt es hier noch immer
kaum die Industrie von dessen im Süden
Deutschlands aber viel gibt ist heute so
richtig am Produzieren und braucht
dementsprechend viel Strom mehr als es
gerade in Süddeutschland gibt und wer
jetzt denkt ja wir schicken den Halt den
überflüssigen Windstrom von der See
Fehlanzeige das geht nicht jederzeit die
großen Übertragungsnetz in Deutschland
sind doch immer nicht gut genug
ausgebaut und dementsprechend häufiger
überlastet
damit es jetzt aber zu keiner
unterlastung in Bayern und keiner
Überlastung im Norden kommt müssen die
Netzbetreiber einen sogenannten redespet
durchführen dabei bewirken sie durch
temporäre zwangsverordnungen dass der
Strom jeweils vor und nach dem Netz
Engpass ausgeglichen wird das Problem
also lokal behoben wird in unserem
Beispiel heißt das dass sie in Bayern
die Gaskraftwerke auf Volllast
hochfahren und zeitgleich die Windkraft
Räder an der See vom Netz nehmen super
ärgerlich das sind Milliarden 1 €
jährlich die einfach verpuffen und
zusätzlich bekommen die Beteiligten auch
noch Ausgleichszahlungen für den
entstandenen Schaden insgesamt also eine
ziemlich teure Angelegenheit so ein
Video Pech sowohl fürs Klima als auch
für den Geldbeutel denn den Preis für
eine redest Patch zahlen wir alle über
die Netzentgelte mit und die Kosten
steigen das liegt auch daran dass sowas
immer häufiger notwendig wird was früher
vielleicht einmal die Woche vorkam
passiert mittlerweile teilweise mehrmals
am Tag
das ist aber nicht der Grund für den
Strompreisanstieg zumindest nicht den
der vergangenen Monate einen der
Verantwortlichen den kennt ihr Russland
die Sache mit dem Marit order-effekt und
den Gaskraftwerken erklärt unter anderem
warum der Strompreis steigt wenn das Gas
teuer ist zumindest dann wenn wir viel
Strom brauchen aber die Sonne nicht
scheint aber warum brauchen wir gerade
so viel Strom für die Antwort auf diese
Frage müssen wir nicht nach Osten
sondern nach Westen zu unseren
französischen Nachbarn gucken bonjour
denn sowohl das Stromnetz als auch der
Strom Markt sind europäisch wenn wir mal
mehr Strom brauchen als wir haben können
wir das bei einem unserer Nachbarn
Einkaufen aktuell ist es jedoch eher so
dass die bei uns einkaufen denn
Frankreich das Land zu der Atomenergie
hat in den letzten Monaten teilweise nur
noch die Hälfte der Stromleistung aus
Atomkraft im eigenen Stromnetz dafür
gibt es vor allem drei Gründe zum einen
sind die Maila alt im Schnitt wohl um
die 37 Jahre dabei sind sie meistens nur
für 40 Jahre Lauf ausgelegt gewesen
zweite Grund ist generell der schlechte
Zustand in den vergangenen Monaten sind
immer mehr und mehr Meiler aufgrund von
Sicherheitsbedenken und für
Wartungsarbeiten vom Netz genommen
worden die in der corona-pandemie
teilweise nicht durchgeführt wurden und
der dritte Grund ist der Klimawandel
höchstpersönlich durch den trockenen
Sommer waren die Flüsse auch in
Frankreich extrem niedrig so niedrig
dass einige Atommeiler ihre Leistung
drosseln mussten weil es ihnen
schlichtweg an Kühlwasser fehlte im
September waren aus dieser Vielzahl an
Gründen 27 von 56 französischen
Reaktoren nicht im Betrieb was daraufhin
schon mindestens seit Dezember letzten
Jahres passiert könnt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich denken die Franzosen
müssen Strom aus dem Ausland zu kaufen
das steigert auch die Nachfrage in
Deutschland was wiederum den Strompreis
hier zu Lande in die Höhe treibt tada
aber kommen wir zurück zu den
erneuerbaren Energien es wurde ja schon
in den letzten Minuten mehrmals deutlich
die Erneuerbaren ziehen im aktuellen
Strommarkt unter anderem wegen Netz
Engpässen häufig den kürzeren wie können
wir das Lösen das große Zauberwort heißt
Flexibilisierung die Stromerzeugung wird
durch die erneuerbaren Energiequellen
immer flexibler ein Teil der Lösung
steckt daher im Ausbau von
entsprechender Infrastruktur mehr
Speicher und mehr Netzkapazitäten wie
und warum das hilft könnt ihr
ausführlich in unserem Video von vor
drei Wochen sehen das findet ihr hier
oben und auch unten in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt aber auch
unseren Strommarkt müssen wir anpassen
erst müssen die großen Verbraucher
flexibler werden und dann kommen wir die
kleinen Verbraucher die Forschung
diskutiert eine ganze Reihe an
Möglichkeiten wie wir das
bewerkstelligen können und als Beispiel
habe ich hier mal drei für euch
ein möglicher Hebel ist der wides Patch
so wie wir ihn gerade beschrieben haben
ist das ein kostenbasierter redest Patch
was aber in der Wissenschaft diskutiert
wird ist ein marktbasierter Red dispatch
hier könnten die Marktteilnehmer ihre
Ausgleichsleistung als Dienstleistung
anbieten der Vorteil das würde Anreize
schaffen solche aufzubauen in Form von
dezentralen speichern zum Beispiel oder
in Form von flexiblen Prozessen in der
Industrie statt Zwangsmaßnahmen
durchsetzen zu müssen könnten die
Netzbetreiber den Ausgleich an einem
eigens dafür gedachten Markt handeln und
ja ich weiß das wäre dann noch ein
stromaggt ein bisschen blöd aber er
könnte die benötigte Flexibilität als
Geschäftsmodell interessant machen
einige Länder wie z.B die Niederlande
machen das schon und die EU schreibt es
seit kurzem als Regelfall vor hier in
Deutschland läuft die Diskussion noch
der größte Kritikpunkt ist dass ein
marktbasierter redest Patch auch Anreize
schaffen würde gezielt einen Netz
Engpass zu provozieren um anschließend
an ihn zu verdienen
dieses Risiko kann man vielleicht
minimieren indem man Deutschland in vier
Preiszonen unterteilt wie zum Beispiel
in Skandinavien aber auch da ist man
sich in Deutschland noch nicht einig
eine andere Lösung die diskutiert wird
wäre eine andere Berechnung der
Netzentgelte das sind die Gebühren die
alle auch wir zu Hause dafür zahlen dass
wir das Stromnetz und seine Leitungen
nutzen damit gibt es im Hinblick auf die
Erneuerbaren aber mehrere Probleme eines
davon ist es wird unter anderem anhand
der größten Last berechnet die man in
einem Jahr auf einmal über das Netz
bezogen hat wenn ich also heute eine
riesige Menge Strom beziehe und den Rest
des Jahres nur sehr wenig dann hebt das
trotzdem mein Netzentgelt an das macht
es natürlich sehr unattraktiv dann Strom
in großen Mengen einzukaufen wenn gerade
viel da ist dabei sollten Verbraucher
genau das tun auch hier könnte der Markt
flexibler werden wenn sich entsprechende
Regularien ändern würden
Flexibilität also das ist ja alles schön
und gut aber was geht uns das als kleine
Verbraucher an wir werden schließlich
über Standard Last Profile abgerechnet
was wir tatsächlich wann verbrauchen
erfasst ja noch nicht mal irgendjemand
nun noch nicht das könnte sich mit
fortschreitenden Digitalisierung ändern
denn einige inklusive der EU träumen
davon dass wir alle digitale Stromzähler
bekommen oder auch Smart Meter ein
kommunikationselement das im Gegensatz
zu unserem aktuellen Stromzähler in zwei
Richtungen funktioniert man kann nicht
nur die eigenen verbrauche einsehen
sondern sendet darüber hinaus auch
Informationen über seinen Verbrauch ans
Netz immer für 15 Minuten Zeiträume so
wie bei normalen lastprofilen wenn diese
Informationen verfügbar sind könnte man
die flexibilitäten von uns kleinen
Verbrauchern besser einbinden so
argumentieren die Befürworter vielleicht
muss man dann auch weniger häufig einen
redest Patch durchführen Gegner haben
vor allem Bedenken in Sachen Datenschutz
und cybersicherheit und hier muss man in
der Tat bei der herstellerwahl ein Auge
drauf haben
es könnte sich aber lohnen für alle die
zu Hause selbst Strom erzeugen hat ein
digitaler Stromzähler auf jeden Fall
Vorteile mit ihm kann man Verbrauch und
Erzeugung also zum Beispiel den Strom
vom eigenen Solar Dach besser
auseinanderhalten so könnte sich die
Abrechnung grundlegend verändern denn
aktuell bezahlen Solarpanel Besitzer
mehr für eine Kilowattstunde die sie aus
dem Netz beziehen als sie für eine
Kilowattstunde bekommen die sie von
ihrem Solarpanel ins Netz einspeisen
auch die Abrechnung nach flexiblen Tarif
Modellen etwa für Tag und Nachtstrom
oder zukünftig je nach Wetter und
Strompreis lassen sich so technisch
lösen ein Beispiel mit einem
entsprechenden Stromanbieter kann ich
mein E-Auto automatisiert bei viel Wind
laden lassen wenn der Strom gerade
besonders günstig ist und zahle dann
auch tatsächlich weniger pro
Kilowattstunde das wiederum hilft
demnetz denn je mehr Verbraucher
flexibel sind und den erneuerbaren Strom
dann abnehmen wenn er in großen Mengen
anfällt desto besser
ein solcher Anbieter von flexiblen
Stromtarifen ist übrigens tippbar die
uns auch bei der Erstellung dieses
Videos hier unterstützt haben bei Tipper
könnt ihr Strom quasi in Echtzeit vom
Strommarkt beziehen damit habt ihr die
Möglichkeit Strom dann zu verbrauchen
wenn er gerade besonders günstig ist die
aktuellen Preise könnt ihr euch direkt
in der Tipper App ansehen damit könnt
ihr dann einfach planen wann ihr z.B die
Waschmaschine laufen lasst euer E-Auto
ladet oder mit sündhaft teurer
Weihnachtsdeko die Nachbarn ärgert auf
den Strompreis kommt dann tatsächlich
keine gewinnmarsche für Tipper oben
drauf ist halt wirklich den echten
Strompreis am Markt und eine monatlich
fixe Servicegebühr von 3,99 €. wenn ihr
also regelmäßig Strom zu günstigen
Zeiten kauft kann das schon zu spürbaren
Einsparungen führen zusätzlich helft ihr
damit auch noch der Netzstabilität und
der Umwelt denn Strom ist wie schon
erwähnt dann besonders günstig wenn
gerade viel aus erneuerbaren Quellen
kommt
wenn ihr einen digitalen Stromzähler zu
Hause habt bietet euch tippbar mit dem
Strom Tracker pals eigene Hardware an
mit der ihr euren Verbrauch in Echtzeit
auf der App abrufen könnt und mit
Gadgets wie dem Hals verdient übrigens
timber sein Geld und eben nicht durch
den Verkauf von Strom selber wenn ihr
euren Strom also flexibel günstig und
nachhaltig Einkaufen wollt dann schaut
gerne mal unter dem ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung bei Zimmer vorbei ach
ja und mit dem Code Watson bekommt ihr
nach Vertragsabschluss noch einen 50 €
Gutschein für den Tipper Store und
unterstützt gleichzeitig auch noch uns
und unsere Videos der Wechsel dauert in
der Regel nur 5 Minuten und wenn ihr
nicht zufrieden seid könnt ihr innerhalb
von zwei Wochen einfach wieder kündigen
vielen Dank an dieser Stelle auch noch
mal an Tipper für die Unterstützung bei
diesem Video also egal ob so ein Smart
Meter und Stromanbieter was für euch ist
oder nicht insgesamt sollte der
Strommarkt der Zukunft deutlich
flexibler werden in diesem Sinne ich
schalte jetzt mal das Licht aus
ist nämlich ziemlich teuer der Strom
gerade macht's gut wie immer und bleibt
neugierig euer Cedric unter anderem
wegen netzengpässen Netz Engpässen
die die
die die die
Windräder an der See vom die Windräder
an der die windkraftfeder
und zeitgleich die Windkraft